it's the gun that rules parts of
venezuela now
this is the only way of stopping looters
in maracaibo
and the vigilantes guarding the shops
have orders to shoot to kill if
necessary
i think anybody in our situation would
have done the same
we had to protect ourselves and our
future
after days of power cuts maracaibo
descended into anarchy
[Music]
it was a free-for-all after years of
deprivation
the people decided to help themselves
in this previously unseen footage
obtained by sky news
there is panic and chaos on the streets
the few police around struggled to
control the masses
law and order has broken down
everything the looters
took everything rampaging through this
hotel and more than
500 other stores and businesses
everything which could be taken was
taken
they hacked through the ceilings to rip
out the copper wiring
and every fixture and fitting was stolen
there are five floors in this hotel and
they're
all like this every single room has been
torn to shreds
every ceiling has been brought down
everything's stripped
there's even blood on the walls as
they've hacked their way through here
using machetes and guns there are
millions of dollars
worth of damage just in this hotel alone
this wasn't just about hunger this was
years of pent-up frustration
they were outside
here
in the orgy of stealing some of the
supermarkets lost
every single bit of stock
the food disappeared off all the shelves
so too
did everything else the scale of the
anarchy has stunned the city
small outlets and big corporations like
this soft drinks warehouse
were equally targeted you can see
the place has been absolutely stripped
of everything every single
bottle has gone our presents disturbed
looters still at work
picking over the remains amongst the
debris this is a city still very much on
edge
it's tasted lawlessness and it wouldn't
take much to tip it again
many of the looters don't see themselves
as thieves
we persuaded one to talk to us he lives
from hand to mouth
collecting scrap he joined the throng of
looters
but was stopped by a policeman who fired
at him as he ran away
then grabbed all the loot for himself
he showed us his injuries caused by
shotgun pellets
he can't afford the medicine to treat
the wound
all my life i felt honest but in this
situation
i felt obliged to loot along with my
neighbors
but this was also about wanton
destruction
this was an electronic store and cafe
now reduced to ashes
once plundered the looters set fire to
it
a show of sheer anger in the country's
second city
which overwhelmed the security forces of
the nicolas maduro regime
control may have been restored but for
how long
alex crawford sky news maracaibo
venezuela